now all have a seat so I hope you guys
know each other much better we'll be
spending at least few hours with one
another so thank you so much for coming
down once again this morning so for now
any further ado help us and kick off
this whole entire morning and this
entire session but Pacifico Ventrella
tech guru to start off this session
thank you hello yep hey everyone welcome
to our workshop on an 11 new X with
reactor ducts
so before we start off how many of you
know reactor ducts Oh quite a few number
there yeah that's good okay so we'll
first I'll first introduce the speakers
and co-facilitators here
Jonathan Alex who's tech lead at palo ID
jonathan is software engineer and myself
guru that will be our today's speakers
co-facilitators today would be aquiline
and shiva they'll be helping you out
with any problems that you have in
setting up workspace or any blockers
that you have yeah so please raise your
hand whenever you have any issue so
they'll come to you and they'll help you
out yeah cool so the agenda for today so
first we'll start off with introduction
about ourselves and what we do next will
straightaway dive into setting up your
workspace then we start off with the
workshop we have we have broken down it
into three small workshops first would
be on style components and themes why
style components and themes would be
first we look into what are the what is
the library that's available to set up a
proper styling architecture and next we
dive into optimistic UX how to set up
optimistic UX app so we'll be using a
chat app for that and finally the final
workshop would be on react performance
how you can make your applications
buttery smooth yeah
coming to an introduction Paulo IT is a
multinational company which specializes
in human centered design and we also do
agile and digital transformations to
many foreign companies we take pride in
telling that we are small enough to care
but big enough to deliver we are around
300 experts from different nationalities
and cultures spread across the globe in
multiple offices at Mexico France Hong
Kong Thailand Singapore and Australia at
Palo we have diverse talent pool which
consists of agile coaches scrum masters
architects developers UX designers data
scientists etc so we have everyone from
the ideation phase to the production
phase
let's straightaway dive into setup and
preparation where facilitators will help
you out
let's get set first please check if you
have the latest version of node.js
Chrome browser because for react
performance we'll be using Chrome
developer tools and you can have your
preferred IDE so if you don't have any
one of these please let us know so we'll
pause if you have latest node.js and
chrome then we will continue everyone
anyone everyone has chrome understant ok
cool
ok so you can clone our github repo
which is over here also we'll be
providing you t-shirts later on so you
can scan the QR code that's on the
t-shirt and it will straight away take
you to the github repository so please
clone this repository and CD into that
workspace folder
yeah it's
here on the screen if you can't see that
oh yeah so this open Wi-Fi network which
you can connect to sorry about that I
didn't inform you beforehand so
shangri-la Wi-Fi network so you can
connect to it no password is required
and you can use that thank you
you
once you have cloned the repoed just
your npm install and you can do a NPM
start so you should get a quick chat app
with just a login page and a home screen
for the chat app
you
all good
done
cool
so next we look into the we look into
the boilerplate why we didn't use create
react app simple reason being for this
workshop we thought it's it's create
react has too many features and it would
be all kill so we just kept it as simple
as possible we also put in a cache
loader there so to make the builds
faster and we have converted all
relative parts within the souls folder
and to absolute path using specific
configuration for Babel transform there
so that's about the bundling and the
build tool coming to webpack statistics
we have also put in a script I can
quickly if you for people who are
familiar with web pack you know that
there's a statistics plug-in which you
can use to to analyze your bundles so
all that you need to do is NPM run stats
so when you do NPM runstats it creates a
bundle and it creates stats for your
bundle I'll give a quick explanation
about that so as you can see you get a
backpack visualizer which tells you what
are the libraries that are taking up
most pace based on percentage and you
have a more detailed view over here so
you can do NPM run stats and you
automatically get this visualization on
your systems
yeah and there's one more proper bundle
analyzer which allows you to see what
are all the libraries under node modules
and what are the libraries that are on
the source folder etc so which library
is taking more space so immutable J's is
something that's consuming more space
this is how you can analyze your bundle
and find libraries which are taking more
space and find alternatives for those
libraries to replace them with so all
that you need to do is NPM runstats
which oh they're so for that we have
created a separate statistic store GS or
this web pack configuration again so you
can look into this and you can create
your own stats pipeline for your
projects so we won't dig deep into this
it's just a quick explanation of why we
have put up that statistic store yes yes
when you do NPM runstats there are 3-3
separate tabs that open up yeah you can
check there are three tabs that open up
like they give different perspective one
would be on the bundle size one would be
showing percentages one would show the
other one is like kind of a detailed
analyze analysis of your bundle which
provides you detailed analysis of your
bundles so there are three tabs that
open up
let's give two minutes the guys who are
having shoes
okay we'll continue because there are a
few more slides where we won't be doing
any workshop so I'll try to explain
further and by the time we'll try to
resolve the issues that you guys are
having yeah okay sure Thanks so we'll
dive into the our first workshop style
components how many of you know style
components here okay very few for people
who know style components yeah it's just
going to be a introduction about style
components how do you do themes how do
you pass drops etc so this would warm
you up this workshop is to warm you up
for what's coming next on optimistic UX
and react performance so let me straight
away show you this this was Google
search engine when it was being demoed
in 1990s so as you can see the CSS that
was used was very basic today if you see
we have such complex applications where
multiple distributed teams are working
on it etc so having a proper style
architecture is very important in your
apps right so let's look into CSS
evolution how we have reached style
components today or CSS in jas it's a
library which represents CSS and J's so
we started off with CSS in 1993 CSS was
just introduced to style scientific
documents web was created for scientific
documents so CSS was just created for
that and nobody knew that CSS would be
what it is today so CS is still alive
and it's doing great but we ran into a
lot of issues with CSS first of all we
used to use inline CSS in the beginning
then you couldn't extend it the way you
wanted to and then came in the important
keyword there which made it even more
difficult for us to understand how
certain CSS is being read by the browser
so to solve that we came up with
pre-processors a CSS less what proposes
did was they brought in mix-ins
variables nesting of your CSS so that
it's easy to understand and read but
what CSS less then solved was a style
architecture which will allow you to
predict or be confident about whatever
Styles that you are writing so after
that came in CSS patterns like them
anyway anyone over here know BEM
what's been yeah can can you tell what's
been can you explain what's been yeah
exactly so it's it's it's a pattern a
block element modifier if you take a
menu a menu is a block a menu item is
element and modifier can be the state
like active or disabled state of your
menu so block element modifier
Convention was used to write your CSS
and also fill up your markup with lot of
CSS class names so disadvantages been
brought in a lot of semantic City into
CSS but at the same time it even made a
mock up unnecessarily semantic it it
blotted the mock up so we had to find a
way to automate BEM okay so that's why
CSS modules came in and react started to
use CSS modules from the beginning and a
lot of our projects today are using CSS
modules what CSS modules brought in was
true encapsulation it automated Ben so
you could just forget about your
component class names having clashes
with other components class names but
CSS modules still didn't bring in the
style architecture predictability and
consistency then in 2007
style components was introduced style
components is a library which implements
CSS in j/s initially there was a lot of
friction because people thought CSS is
going to come to an end if CSS and J's
gets ahead and also people thought it's
not performant but oh the year in 2017
we have seen that style components has
been introduced in many large-scale
projects and it's being used
successfully what a style components
they're just pure visual primitives so
it's pure visual components they use
template little notation of es6 so it
means that they blend es6 and CSS in a
good way so they separate UI from the
functional and stateful components also
one more thing that's very important
when you're working on lots in large
teams is the design and development was
a hand off previously now it can be a
continuous collaboration so you can
build core components not only for the
browser-based apps but also for your
native apps using style components so
let's get started and create a simple
style component and after that we will
look into the theming of style
components and look into how passing
proverbs and how to reuse an extent and
finally in the end I will talk about
what's the future for style components
okay so please check out this branch and
we'll get started from there
also before we start over here as you
can see we have created for each step a
feature branch which has the completed
code so if you are stuck and if you want
to quickly switch to that branch and get
the final code you can switch to that
branch so for style components it will
be step one step two step three step
four Step five so we start off with step
one and we build if you get stuck
anywhere when we are going through any
any of the features you can just switch
to that and you can yeah start coding
from there
once you have checked out branch I will
quickly explain we have also put a
styled coms dot txt in your main
workspace here we have actually created
put in the code that which you can copy
paste into your components whenever we
are trying to do any exercise but I'll
go slow so you you will still be able to
go a code instead of just copy pasting
so if you are stuck you can still copy
paste either switch branch or you can
copy paste from here this one
we aren't able to zoom in yeah
that's out there you don't have to worry
about the code I'll be typing along with
you guys so you can see on my workspace
and you can type along yeah if you want
this code it's already present in your
workspace as I told if you if you go
into style combs dot txt so you have all
the code there yeah
cool let us know when you are ready all
of you if you are ready just let me know
let's start off so if you look into the
code we have app dot JSX
where we have created a rod to style
comp so basically all the screens or
pages are in the routes folder and the
components folder contains a lot of
style components so if you want to see
complex examples about style components
you can look into the components folder
we have created a few style components
which we'll be using in the chat
application later on to keep the work
workshop simple on style components
we'll be just using one single file that
would be style comm dot JSX here as you
can see we have a basic react component
which just renders a button so you can
do NPM start after you switch branch and
you should be able to see our HTML a
button
okay let's let's build a first style
component so in style Comte or JSX
to use style components all that you
need to do is in your packages and just
add a dependency on style components
it's already been added so you need not
do and PM install again so now we import
style components
so you import style components and we
will create a button a style component
as custom button so
so we use template little notation so
and as you can see I'm just hooking into
the native button button element so we
do use backticks we'll just give a
background for it I won't be using hex
notation here I'll just use it as light
blue once that is done you can now
render your custom button
ah I'm sorry I made a spelling mistake
there yeah it's almost yea good morning
everybody I'm sorry to interrupt this
important program for a moment good
morning I hope you settled in quite
nicely on these next between 10 and 11
we have nitro coffee all day when he
allows you to leave only then you may
join us at the hacker deck for a nitro
coffee looks a little bit like a
Guinness with a thick foam on top and
with a cocktail robot there and the
robot reacts to QR codes you find one of
those already on our social media pages
on twitter.com such as Camtasia and
Facebook on flash days come to Asia for
now only the non-alcoholic version later
today you're going to get the alcoholic
version there too so make sure you
follow us you get that QR code just go
to the robots and make your cocktail
that's about it I'll leave it to guru to
make you a great morning from your and
enjoy and I hope you all take something
home from you okay you want to join for
a photo oh yeah just there so I have you
as a hostess oh yeah sure
okay I'm ready Cheers
you want to be in a bit
notice that was the wrong picture q so
you must have your first style component
so we'll film wide so next we look into
how can you pass custom drops it's not
just custom props you can even pass in
attributes HTML attributes to your
button so I'll quickly show you that you
can just make this button disabled and
the button would be disabled so it means
that the HTML attributes are being
passed to the styled component
yeah now let's look into how we can pass
custom props so what we'll do is we'll
create three buttons a small a medium
and a large button and we will see how
we can use the same style component by
passing props to it so we'll create
three buttons we use a fragment tag
yes on which step are you doing up this
that's right just you just know that
tell you I'm on step 2
so we have created our custom props
small medium and large now we are going
to read those props within our style
component so let's create a margin so
that the buttons are spread out let's
put in a margin
so now we use the template neutral
notation to read properties or read
JavaScript within the templating
notation so for that props
and then once we read the props we can
set whatever styling you need so it's
it's CSS dynamically being modified
during runtime so now if you
so if you look in your screen now there
are three buttons with variable sizes
this is how we can pass custom props
yep and it just will feature there would
be
backticks they're not evaluated until
later yeah without sort of in them if we
had stubs on button really Frank it's
what it because I was a writer in a
traditional way
mm-hmm I'm just curious so if I think
you fail use brackets it doesn't work
because it's yeah yeah but would there
be a way I mean I tried doing this but
this didn't work would there be a way to
do it I know
no it uses es6 template little notation
so that's the that's that that's what
style components comes with but if you
look into other CSS and J's libraries
they use other notations like you can
pass in a function and yeah then you can
do a lot of things yeah yeah here
everything would be passed as props and
then you can dynamically switch yeah
[Music]
so it's working yeah we'll move on to
the next topic themes so a style
architecture whenever you're doing any
style architecture you should always
think about themes because you don't
know when how big your product is going
to grow and how many clients would be
buying your product and you might have
to build different themes for different
lines right traditionally how in a
simple way using just CSS how we used to
achieve this so on the body tag you if
you put up a class called theme light or
theme dark okay and you can use any
class classes within for all the
elements within the body and now using
CSS cascading or I would say hierarchy
theme light has button dot primary which
says background like blue and theme dark
as button dot primary which say is
background blue so what we used to do
over here if you have ten themes in your
application we had to package all these
ten themes together
and ship it to the browser's for the
browser to treat them or you could do
lazy loading on on similar lines but now
with CSS nsj you can dynamically change
props variables etc and you can achieve
this one thing that style components
comes in built with is theme provider so
you can have specific sections of your
application running on a certain theme
and other sections running on a
different team if you want okay so we'll
quickly look into how we can create a
theme for two custom buttons and having
different backgrounds so basically by
reading props so for that we need to
first import team provider
and then I'll remove the props for
padding and I'll just give up pairing
off once that is done so you can define
your themes by using objects so we'll
create two teams team one and Team two
so we'll set the primary color to light
blue for team one and for Team two this
is hello
how do you use these props here would be
that within your fragment you can call
the team provider
and to this theme provider you can pass
in your theme object that you just now
created so for the first theme provider
will send it will give it team one as
prop and for this second theme provider
will give team two now you can
copy-paste the custom button within the
theme provider you can remove the small
prop etc
we are done with the JSX mock-up now we
need to read the team one and Team twos
primary color within our style component
so for that it's it's very simple
so you just read props dot team dot
primary and automatically your buttons
should be teamed so now you can use this
theme provider at way various levels so
you can use this team provider at the ad
in your index dot HTML at the global
level and automatically switch teams
between dark light etc based on whatever
is stored in the database for user
preference
so we'll move on to the next topic so we
looked into team provider next topic
would be reusability and extendibility
basically how you can use mix-ins there
is more advanced topic on extent but if
you want to see examples of that if you
go into a components folder we have
style components which are using extent
for now we will quickly see how we can
use a mixin and use those CSS variables
in two different style components so for
that will still use team one and Team
two what we can do is create a constant
as base button which will take in
we'll have a custom button and we'll
create a new button called super button
and now we can read base button props as
mix in within our custom button and
super button so far
and for the super button let's put in
border-radius
so all the code for this is in style
comm dot txt so you can just go in there
and read about it or copy paste if you
are stuck in stuck anywhere so once
that's done now you can use custom
button and super button in your JSX
so as you can see you have custom style
component one custom style component two
one is a custom using custom button
style component and the one is using cus
super custom button component which has
a border radius added to it so this is
how you can reuse variables you can
define themes you can have waves
properties defined and stored in your
database and read in the runtime and
applied to your CSS if we had to achieve
this in using CSS or even as CSS then I
you should have used a lot of lazy
loading techniques etc but now it's it's
total dynamic behavior
if you're that if you're done we'll move
on that's all about style components
workshop if you want to see more complex
examples you can go into the components
folder we have created input which has a
lot of complex style component dynamic
passing props and enabling dynamic
behavior so you can look into it
so what's future of style components
basically washing one had post CSS
pipeline which was cause which was
increasing the built by the pipeline CSS
pipeline for conversion from style comps
to CSS and inject it into your HTML
document the bundle size was big like 21
KB so they switched in version 2 - Silas
but what they missed is Pasillas this
was creating a AST so you could tweak
into the pipeline of post CSS and you
could use it to do your own auto fixing
custom auto prefix prefixes for your CSS
etc and also for left-to-right
transformations but now that's not
possible
so what style components team is coming
up with is something called as intro
parable style transfer format this would
be this is the first CSS in gs format
that they're coming up with so you you
would be able to generate AST abstract
syntax trees and customize how style
components would work for your own need
one thing that we didn't look into was
linting so now the cell components team
has come up with style and processor for
your style components so it's
production-ready linting of your style
components similar to how we could lint
SCSS with sass lane and you're using
year slained
sorry not yes liens CSS lint for CSS so
so we'll quickly summarize so we went
through we looked into CSS evolution how
what a style components what are their
advantages etc we looked into a workshop
a quick workshop on creating style
components passing custom props themes
reusability and extendibility
and we had a short description about
where style components is going in the
future yeah so that was the first
session it was a warm-up session so next
sessions would be even more faster and
we will deep dive into optimistic UX
next after we have a quick five-minute
break
yeah yep thank you
we have small gift for you
webcam colors so we'll go ahead with the
quiz we I don't think we can wait for
the others to come back because we're
running out of time sorry for that so
it's it's easy but it's what you need to
read in between lines so it's going to
cover three concepts I'll explain to you
the concept later on but
what do you think the answer would be
first was yeah sorry that's wrong
yeah that's right undefined is the
answer
reason yeah victus people to inject a
semicolon yeah that's right so a
semicolon is injected and that's why
this object is neglected and you get an
undefined so this just shows that you
should be very careful when you are not
using yeah
how about this
yeah yeah
No
just sticking guys guys yeah I think
it's just drink no sorry for that no no
yeah function for stranger what's
happening here is returning food so the
code below is never going to be reached
so foo is equal to ten is never each but
however function foo would be hoisted to
top of this function right so that's why
it's it's a function yeah
so now let's get seen yes let's see what
this would be
sorry
I will project it here oh my
No
yeah yep anyone DS our core concepts of
JavaScript that we are looking into
first one was when you don't use
semicolons I agree I'm old school so I
still use semicolons so when you don't
use semicolons where you can go wrong
that was the first question about second
one was function for sting and third one
is a little bit more complex in
JavaScript
yes yeah perfect
yeah it's III and one so what we're
looking at here is closures so when
you're doing full bath bar go equal to
this and if you call him go go isn't
looser the global space there so when
you do it's going to print tree and when
you do pub as bar its if the closure
would be within bar but Howard the X is
read on top of that so it's X equal one
so it's 3 comma 1 ok yeah thank you and
we'll continue with our next workshop
hello hello can you guys hear me yep
okay so we're going to do a chat app and
we're going to apply some optimistic UI
or updates on chat on the chat app as
well so before I continue
can I show us of hands who doesn't know
what does we mean by optimistic UI No
okay so optimistic UI here's the the
decryption but ultimately what it means
that when you are sending something to
the server and you assure that maybe 90%
you will not return you an error right
you update the UI first without waiting
for the server to get back to you if
something pass or fail so you give a
psychological speed to the user that you
know everything is fast so very one
example that we can know is if you use
whatsapp right when you send the check
come out first without saying there no
data loading or waiting for the server
to get back to say have you been
successfully delivered so you will just
show and then you have a they go of a
step further with the ticks to show that
if it's delivered or have the user read
if you have those option on so there's
what optimistic UI is and today so we're
going to do a chat app right and then we
can see how can we apply this in our
reactor Redux application so sorry so
the first thing is maybe you can check
out the branch very simple in it cost
Tata
if you can't see have it here as well
yes you know - meows - yeah your privet
run track you either come in or you just
- and then you please check out Tata
after that uh run npm install just in
case there's some dependency that is
needed for this exercise as well
so if you are done you can run NPM start
and you should see a chat app similar to
what you guys will see when you first
check out the clone the repo
and if you guys didn't have a reductive
tools installed on your Chrome please do
install it as well thank you
we might need you may need it later if
you face any problems when you want to
debug issues
so it's a which is everyone done cool
okay so this is what you will see like
on the left is the application and on
the right is a bit uptight too so if you
could set up your brother in such a way
it would be good so if you look at the
application what we can do is we can
type in our username right you can type
in anything right and you enter you'll
bring into the chat room and in the chat
room you can type anything all right
I'll check haha right but you know this
is not connected to any back-end added
yet right so what we're going to do is
we already have a you either it's being
built up for you guys using stock
components we are going to try and see
how are we going to implement this we've
socket and REST API so we're using a
make sure socket and rest to build this
application so before I continue just to
let you guys know that most of it the
code already in in in a code base we
have some code commented out so we will
comment them one by one with them being
it's a shortage of shortage of time and
we want to go to and make sure you guys
understand some concepts like what we
are doing in this project and what are
some practices that we find that it's
good and we are practicing and using it
in our projects as well so before we
continue maybe we can just look in the
folder structure and now explain certain
things so you can see that we have like
this looks like a typical we are
application right those have done via
redux we have similar photo tractor
think that I want to highlight is we
have components and routes so components
like what guru boat went to is a stock
component components right so if you
look what we are doing here you notice
that all these components they are named
story they are named very similar to
your native API so that
one thing to take note when you're
building components right you try to
have it at close to the HTML or CSS API
so for n number of you're building a
flex component right I just need me flag
right for crops that you can pass in
into your components right you can name
anything for your props right but here
you can see that we are using things
like high justified content a line item
flex Direction all these are very
familiar these are from your CSS right
you write your head in such a way so the
advantage of this is any developers that
come to your project right it's very
familiar to them right they don't have
to learn new api's or how you are
building a component so this is one
thing to take note when you're building
your component so in such a way it will
help people to understand and get up to
speed so these are the components that
we have built you can take a look at
them if you want to and these are enough
for you to build each other and we have
the routes in our case browser like the
pager so we have the login page the chat
page so you can see that there are two
photos here you log in and each other
right so these are just your routes next
thing they want to go to HD actions
right we have actions so you can see if
we have a bunch of code commented out so
these are things that we're going to
uncomment them one by one and we slowly
will go through how this will link up
our application together so in our
actions you realize that we are not
doing it in the normal way that we act
our readers is doing so what we are
doing here is you're using it like we
call redux egg okay if what happened who
have used without text before no one
okay then I will explain what is this
and why we are using it right so when
you create a a action in your react
application most of the time you create
a constant that goes with your action
type right because you want to prevent
pairing our errors and things like that
but if you notice here we did
need to create any constant for our
action type so why we ducks like this
doing is you just create just put a
string here which is your action pipe
actually and what they are doing in the
baggage they are helping you to enforce
that your actions and unique as well so
they have like some kind of ID there's
in a pen prepended before your action
type so if you were to see ok so you can
see here the type right it's what we
write as we eat but if you if you don't
put a type right it would be an ID so
they're helping you to make sure that
this is unique all the time right so
what they are doing if you look in our
reducer right the way so the way we are
using a reducer we are just importing
the actions variable that we created so
they are doing some what is happening is
they are overriding the to shrink method
so when you have an object this is an
object and you have the computer key
right what's happening is JavaScript
will call the tostring method so this is
how they are handling the type for
catching the action so these one thing
it's actually quite interesting you can
you guys can take a look because it
reduces the boilerplate of writing your
constant because every action you have
all the time you have a constant right
so you cut down on our boilerplate and
it makes your code easier to read as
well
one other thing that I want to highlight
is the way we are using our writing our
code in a reducer we have this pipe
right thinking of pipe as a series of
functions that we are piping to it just
like your normal pipe in your Linux and
everything your piping to our input to
the various function right so now what
we are doing is we are actually piping
the state through this Paris very very
well function so you can see
over here let's just say we have the
actions and check message right what we
are doing is we are actually having this
function they're taking a payload and a
state that's well it I'll show you how
where the state comes in right
so if taking a state and returning a new
state to the next function so you're
returning the next state to the next
function and then ultimately when this
finish you will return the state to the
reducer okay and then that's where the
reducer will get a new state and then
the whole app app react application will
be render so the concept of this right
we have what we call this mutators
recording mutators because they mutate
only one part of the state that
constants then right so for example if
you were to look at our
mutaters right you can see what we are
doing here is let's say set input i just
want to care about these path inputs the
name and the value and also set the
value to this path so we're using
immutable J's here so you can see it's a
bit weird you know we do not have like
object not assign and then we create a
new object so we're using in the
turbojet we have us to ensure the
immutability of our state as well one
other reason why we use this is because
it helps you to maintain a very clean
with you sir imagine if you have a very
deep state what you have is you have
reducer composing reducer and readin
reducer and when you want to traverse
through your code you need to go through
this video so and you say oh this is
actually handled by another video so
you're going into that with you sir and
you realize that then another reducer
and composing so it would be very deep
and very hard to traverse through the
code so which is why when if you use
this because you can just put the path
and you will just go to that value so if
it's hard to understand just take it if
if the object you'll be object dot input
not mean value so this is what we are
doing
and because the way we are doing we
ensure that the mutaters only handle one
thing
and one thing only so it's very small
right which makes it very easy to test
as well so when you have a very big
application you can have all these it's
very easy to test and you can reuse them
right because you have you probably have
a bunch of inputs right you can have
inputs and you have the dynamic puffier
because of the name of the input right
so that is why we are using a murder but
just in this application as well so that
is just a short when walkthrough of the
cone and why we are using certain things
any questions at this moment like
anything is unsure or you are if anyone
is lost everybody okay
okay so we are going to start to try and
build this chat application before I go
on just to let you guys know that this
is how we are breaking down the reaction
so all the different colors actually the
different components that works we have
taken out as a component by itself so
this is just a feature for you guys to
see just in case if you need it so so
what I'm going to do so we're going to
work on the logic only today so we have
the actions the mutaters the reducers
and lastly the middleware so we're going
to use the middleware to do this socket
connection and the rest API call
overhead anyone have those who have done
yet redux anyone has brought your own
middle west before anybody heard about
Middle West anybody know what middleware
is okay a few hands okay so the rest
assume you don't wanna meter worry
how about you how the middle words like
but before that here are a few events
that we're going to send so we have
combination of socket and the rest right
so for socket right we have this event
at user and for the rest we have this
API endpoint not to worry this arch in
the code just giving you guys a visual
and these are the socket event that
we're going to listen
to login success login fail so we are
going to implement this this login part
right so what we have to do is actually
we need to kena username we sent to the
server the server tell us if if
userexists evidence it logins as test so
you're giving a login success event if
it fails there will be a login fail
because a user have already existed
right so these are what we're going to
build so before we go on just talking
about Midwest so this is a flow of
application right normal yet we just
application you have a store right
normally yes the view will listen to the
store you having action right normally
the action go straight to the video sir
right but in this case we have the
middleware with your handle our socket
or REST API okay reason being why we
want you to be the middleware because
like if we want to do anything that is
related to in your normal we are and
redux application normally we have
actions to describe something that has
happened right or something that you
want to change so you want to maintain
the same way where you want to execute
your socket middleware and rest as well
so we are test is why we are using a
middleware because we want to use
actions for adding any changes that we
want to make to the application so
middleware just think it of the actions
we will just pass through middleware you
can have a few Midwest so you go to a
series or middle west actually if you
have more than one min away will
intercept your actions those action that
they need to intercept and what what
happen is it can do many things you can
either stop the action from going to the
reducer or you can even dispatch new
action as well - which is why you can
see some time in the way you can
dispatch new action and you'll go to
again so this is the concept of
middleware and it is the core part that
we're going to build today for little
application right so without further ado
let's go to the code and let's go to our
actions right
so the first thing to do that we know
that we want to add a user right over
here we need to add a user to the socket
so we know that we need it like I said
before we need the action so if you go
to the action on line fine just
uncomment line five the code right I
happy and user to chat right and we are
creating an action here and we know that
these action need to be handed need to
be intercepted by the middleware and we
need a socket configuration as well
right because you need to tell them cut
these action what are the events I'm
going to emit so here can we open the
socket config dot yes
okay so you can see that in this I have
a function called socket set up socket
right and instead of okay I have two
other functions that is being returned
by the setup socket function right we
have a listener and emitter so if you
are using a socket right you have a
socket that actually watched on the
event so in this case the first one can
see we are actually what watching on
this socket long gains access right so
this is where in this function we are
putting on our socket event that were
listening to so that's why this in the
function called listener and then we
have another one right we should call
the emitter this is where we have look
at this is a very similar API in our
reducer right because we're using the
Redux act and we're looking on the
action so this action right when he
intercept this action I want to sock it
to any user event and then the payload
user name so your action will actually
pass our user name right so our action
achieve a positive user name and then
this will pass to the socket back-end so
the thing is in order for this to happen
you need new socket object which will be
passing from this set up socket right so
now let's go try we have two two event
here one day will emitting at user and
if it's successful you should receive
login success okay and let's just also
uncomment this on line seven right this
is login field so if you login fail to
see you can see that here we are
dispatching another action right so if
you look over here when we have the
actions right we come to the middleware
what happen is if we in it
adduser you go to the stockade logins
fail success it will come back to the
middleware and your dispatch and other
actions back right because here we are
dispatching action to change our state
okay so when okay so if once we have
uncommented that we have the
configuration for this to event to event
so now the thing is we need to pass in
this socket events right so where we are
initializing the socket is in store
touch yes so if you can go to store yes
you see we can from line 9 or 13 sorry
line 13 all the way down we can
uncomment and we can remove like no
sorry yeah this like this so we move
[Music]
okay nevermind okay so you can see what
I'm trying to show you here is we have
this setup socket right we are importing
it here Tara talking and here is where
we implement our socket connections so
we have a socket object and when we call
right this is okay the socket object it
been being passed to this function here
so this function which is the same
function as this is having access to
this socket connection okay so this is
how you pass your socket object into
these functions so that they have access
to the or have the scope to this socket
object
so these how we can pass it in and then
you notice that this socket middleware
here so what is this this is where we
have the middleware which is part of
redux right that will handle all this
they were passing things that you need
like for a number you see you have Jax
get state test age and dispatch right so
whether these come from this actually
come from the middle way stuff so when
you use the middleware Envy ducts they
are actually passing you a few other
items you can stay dispatch and
reactionary actually right so if you can
see here actually like that if let's
look at the socket middleware right so
right is in this if in the middle way
folder and that's a there's fall cost
okay yes so if you look at this example
me the way right this is a signature of
a middle way so if you want to create a
middle where this is the signature you
have to follow so it's actually a
carrying of three functions right you
see that that's a store that's an X and
that's action right in next is actually
calling your next meter way so if you
have a media went from example either
way like neither wave I mean aware to
amedeo when one makes will be calling
middleware to write and it means the way
to your next actually calling the
dispatch function right so your last
middleware next will be the dispatch
function else the first few we know will
always be calling thank you always be
calling the next meter way right so this
is the signature of a middleware so if
you want to Bill me the way just take
note of the signature like this so you
see here when if I call next and I
passing the action so when it connects
you have the path in the action because
you are saying that okay I want this
action right from here to go to the
middleware to the next one right so if
you don't want the action to go true
means you want to intercept the action I
say maybe I don't do anything you don't
pass you don't you don't connect and
that's how you can in a sense silence
some actions but that might not be
always the case that you want so just
depend on what other use are your use
case and you just do it like this so
let's look over so kami the way
okay it might be a bit hard to see but
what I'm trying to show you is that
remember we pass in our socket object
right okay this it's a sock at me the
way ding
all right so here on the right side you
can see that at the end I'm returning
the listener and emitter these two
functions right and if you look over
here and the sock at me the way you can
see that it actually comes to here the
listener and the emitter so this is how
your socket middleware get access to
these two function which you have just
created right and you can see the
listener so it's actually so the meter
wave actually tree function call right
tree is carrying of tree functions when
you apply the meter where you actually
activate the first function which is
calling this part so they were actually
past redux where actually passed the
store and called it and that's why I
have the liver so they meet a point
applying the middleware I'm already
listening to the events from the socket
right but it's a bit different for the
emitter so you can see the emitters here
because emitter is waiting for an action
right is it I want to eat meat something
I want to mean something to the pocket
you use the action to describe that
change so which is why it's over here
and we think for the actions to be
passive so when you dispatch an action
over here you go to the middleware and
this is where we interests a bit and
have a party interaction right so if you
look back again
in the socket configuration right you
can see that here we are actually
looking to a user to chat right so if
the actions come here you go this and
then you'll Amin right everybody's
following so far right so if you have
uncommented all these and you should
have the socket uncommented as well
let's just see this should work if we go
to the application Oh
sorry guys uh we don't have the rest
meter way yet so can you just remove it
from the middle way so just have only
this time setup socket and yeah
so if we were to try
let me just see
oh we need to go to the component the
login component there's this code the
forms I mean you need to switch it
because previously it was just we are
just doing a history push so we're just
only changing the route but you can see
here uncomment this off we move the top
one so now this is actually dispatching
the user to chat so we actually
dispatching the username over here which
we actually store in a state when they
type right so on every input we are
actually storing every single input in
the reader store
yeah so just remove it and we should be
good to go we go to the chat application
the function
Oh
is anybody able to log log in no right
okay
give me a moment
but you can take weird
Oh
okay
okay
silly mistake this action if you have an
uncommon please uncomment it like save
username so you can see that uh over
here right we have add the user and same
username is actually dispatched by my
middleware right in the socket
configuration right see here we are
dispatching tape username so this is how
you can implement the socket into this
middle way so everybody you can see the
can everybody log in anybody can log in
so if you can log in the rest is pretty
much the same right because the rest of
our action over here right these are all
pointing to all our socket actions
so just uncomment all these right and we
can go to the action the the socket
configuration as well uncomment all this
right so two places and comment the
coding autocoding socket don't compete
and your actions touch it so you can see
that all this year are listening to the
different event and then dispatching the
respective actions to your store and
then they will update the Redux store
and your application will be vendor then
later we can see how we can have the
whole chatter position one more thing we
did is for the socket events we haven't
done it for the REST API right so
because the way we send our message
we're sending to rest while the rest of
the events we are listening to the
socket events so if you have done this
we have
in either where folder there's none of
Falkor rest is just uncomment the code
in there so this is a very simple
fashion right we're just doing a pause
on this URL where we post the message
that we're going to stand later in a
child right so this is also meter where
if you take a look at it right we have
the same signature the dispatch right
the next and the action so you can see
that the only difference is that I put
I'm putting the configuration in this
bit away but normally you're shifting
out to somewhere if you have a series of
API calls to make but for simplicity I'm
just going to put it here okay so once
you have uncommented this code in
restaurant yes the next thing you need
to do is to you need to include it in
the list of middleware that you have
right installed yes so if you go to
stores yes remember the one that we
remove this now right there's a second
turn up socket and then that's a red
middleware so just uncommon at the read
middleware yeah
right
so if steal is done if you try to log
into the chatroom right and you type
something or someone type something we
should all be able to see it because
these are connected to our socket
back-end server so those who managed to
finish it
oh yeah you need to uncomment a cone in
your video sir as well because the
reducer have to change watch the action
and change the state right so need to
ankle many of it uses the the Ori
actions in a video sir
dito what you should go to potato oh
yeah someone else with the same and the
username as a book so we need to add
something value value don't usually but
sometimes oh ok ok ok can anybody say oh
yeah
yep so you should be able to see
something like this where you can see
range of people joining the chat and
leaving the chat where were types well
right before Easter okay
yeah if you know I may be here hey guys
don't type in empty user name okay the
type mean uh if you have ready time when
you enter you the name you can leave the
chat come in go back right then you tell
me something right because we didn't
check for empty strings in this case
okay so this is a chat app there are we
have just few but how does it link to
optimistic UI right so if you can see if
I have an error message right I that
this is an error right so we look up for
the error name in the server so
okay this way let me just check for
oh yeah to lowercase yeah yeah away told
em to put empty empty using yeah they
can live in join again yeah believe that
because right
yeah
what oh do you have ever
okay for those of you have used the
mirror I just add this in your mutaters
the pen order message write yourself
check if username is coming right if
it's not coming then it's not we will
not run if condition
you can ask a parlor suite sure to find
my branch yeah okay
because there is no working I don't know
why okay so we have those who are not
able to compete all don't worry we have
a dis branch no [ __ ]
so stop get can you just check out to
this ok client done rights okay - client
done right you have the full working
application so just like I'll do that
Danna we've talked a bit on the
optimistic UI before we add
please do a good stash and then you can
check out socket climb done each check
also get client oh yeah [ __ ] a lot
right yes good so once you have checked
out you should have something similar
like and I was saying that right if
there's an error message I can see that
it this this one rate right it was green
before and now it turned red so this is
actually a simulation of in any case if
the Machine get true right the server
will tell our application that didn't
get true and what we have to do if we
just need to take different actions
because in your different application
you have different way of handling error
messages that if he doesn't go true
let's say in this case the change
message right sometimes you can add them
to from them to resend or you could have
a logic to say okay if this fails I will
try to send it again right and maybe for
three times before it really timeout and
then I will show the error message to
the user so where are we implementing
this if you look in our rest client
right you can see on this line right if
that changes very simple right
we're just looking for some error
message if there's an error message with
the special action right that describe
that change the state on to to to show
the error message right so it's just a
very simple idea right don't need to
have any complex framework or what to
help you hand I know there are some that
there are some optimistic UI framework
or middleware as well to help you had
noticed but it can just be as simple as
dispatching an action to correct certain
things so in this case where we have we
are just correcting changing it to red
and then sending the recent button so if
the user have to they can click the
reason and we send the message again
so that many different ways you can use
to handle your optimistic UI right so
thing so just to close in summary like
one of the things that we have went to
in this thing is that we use the API as
close as possible to data standard so
like the HTML CSS which I mentioned in
the components that you have right for
any changes you need in the application
always use redirection so for anything
that you have it always standard
especially after two it's very easy
change something
dispatch action change that dispatch
session right and of course if you need
to have any asynchronous or start
effects you will user we you use the
middle way so that is all thank
this time the only questions you will be
having placed the code okay so all that
you need to do is please check out
stockist over first first of all because
you need you to npm install and then you
NPM stock so stock yourself
it's - okay so uh do a git checkout quiz
please don't log in once git checkout
quiz is done please do our npm install
once you run npm install you can start
please don't login into your chat app
yet because we get to know when you join
in when you leave so
you designed it up using an adopted is
never wrong
are you done everyone
okay now you can log-in with your name
your first name
please give your first name - because we
need to get to know who was loved in so
login with your first name
now you can there's a quiz button there
please click on that quiz button and
please take this quiz as soon as
possible and [ __ ] who gets all the
answers right and it's also based on
time will get will be the winner yep
it was interesting to explain the
concept we're just in the experimental
data and who explained nineteen people
are still trying to make it work so you
need always to her
Sylvain has like score of 5 so it's not
the first one cell is the first one so
everything looked right right makes it 7
hmm that's really cool
right when I took the test I thought
poor Putin like summons was wins so I
just got three that's that's good so
your scores are way better
you have three three more minutes
so Rama's go seven Alexis five and then
six Ricardo seven again oh love who is
love
come on anyone I was having and it's ah
that's good okay if you are done
how many just a taking the quiz okay
okay Oh another eight there
last chance last chance yeah 30 seconds
more because yes please check nobody's
going up so everyone is done right okay
so let's see who is the winner so it's
gonna be eight yeah
who is the first date joy joy next next
my legs are taking the Panda and he will
thank you with the next workshop it
would be a nice setup okay
it's going it's going okay
okay everyone so this is the last
session I think we are a little short on
time so I will try to go a little faster
okay but don't worry here the purpose of
this workshop exercising is good but
what we want to show you is some tooling
that will help you to do some
performance checkup and also some
libraries that can be helpful if you
want to optimize the way you code for
taking conservation performance okay
okay it's coming cool thanks so who has
been working Oh has already tried to
improve the performance of your
application is there anyone no okay so
then maybe this one will be interesting
so during this session though as I told
you the purpose is to show you some
tools to show you some libraries and
also to try for you to understand what's
behind how does the react component walk
hold up who day they are under to know
how to optimize it okay so first you can
commit and stash your previous walk and
check out the react performance workshop
branch there's two branch react
performance workshop and react
performance solution okay so if you want
to go directly to resolution that's fine
also if you want to try to do it you can
also but I will go a little faster then
not forget when p.m. install an NPM
start
okay if you enter them start you will
see you again to chat please enter our
name okay so that we don't have the same
bug as previously don't forget to enter
name before entering your chat also if
you can if you already unique chrome and
for those who didn't have can you try to
install the react developer tools so you
can search on google react developer
tools so this one so previously john
asked you to install the reduced tools
now we need I don't want the react
developer tools okay
okay everyone is set is there somebody
not set yet okay so then let's start it
so once you're on once you connect to
the application so you can just connect
to the chatroom
you will see in this chatroom what I did
is that initially a lot of messages or a
repetitive message just for the purpose
of this offer this demonstration also I
added here another component which is a
mention it count how many time people
had in writing
jion's conf or poly whitey in their
message right if I add value YT and GS
conf again the mention is increasing
okay so nothing a nothing exceptional
here it seems to be working fine right
before starting the looking at the tools
there just one thing I will go very fast
for those who are using a rack already
know for those who are learning it you
just know about this that there's two
way off for building your app one is a
development project development build
and one is a prediction build right the
difference is that when you do
prediction build he will remove a lot of
warning that you can see in the console
log so it will make you up a much more
small small okay so don't forget to do
that what you need is to add a not off
in in the in your application when you
when you build it so an example for web
pack if you're using webpack as we did
you can see in our web pack that we have
in the web app - web pack five one for
development and one for production if I
make a search on the development I will
not find production if I make the search
on production oops sorry
then you can see here we are setting up
the non off to production okay
the other thing for optimization that is
recommend is don't forget to amplify or
minify for the production record I look
so the same on my production here on my
production webpack there is a plug in
for Allah fiying that we set it here on
development we don't need to do that
because we want to have the whole code
loading in our browser so we are not
doing okay fine okay so how to check if
you if the current app you are running
is in production or in development mode
you can use the react developer tools if
you look at the once you install it you
can see here there's two color if he's
red it means you are in development mode
if I click he's tell you you're in
development mode if you build it in
production mode production build you
will have a duck icon okay so this one
is a just a quick a quick check up on on
this build - this is the basic stuff but
if you never do reactors know about this
okay this will improve the performance
already of your production then let's
try to go deeper up there's another tool
okay here in Europe it seems to be fine
right I tap is very fast and it's show
very fast here but let's say you are
walking you your app is walking very fun
and know some people are deploying your
app in the mobile app maybe the mobile
app is not as strong as your computer
and they will start to have some latency
the chrome give us the tools if you open
you develop you instant you develop burn
inspect the tools in the chrome you will
see here there's the tabulation
performance okay in performance you have
on the right here sitting you can
simulate a footling so i can voluntarily
tell chrome can you be four times slower
than usual okay
everyone has that
okay so I can repeat open you inspection
inspect tool in your Chrome browser go
to the performance performance on the
right there's a smaller setting icon if
you open it you have a CPU normally you
are not switching is what working as
normal but you can simulate a throttling
okay it won't set up once you do that I
go to the chat again now I start to type
and start to be a little slow I feel
some latency when I entered you see
there's a one-second latency is the
little slower than when I was not typing
when I was not at rattling okay so then
we are going to start to use a tool to
find out if you can find out how to
improve this this latency okay so there
is a tool in the same tab that we
already showed this graph so this graph
is a color
flan graph okay you can see that it show
when you are running the app how long
each component is taking and which
component is is calling which component
to be built in the reactor application
so to do that you have on the left here
a small record button okay so when I
click it it will start recording my
action so just for this for this Duvall
please stop stop entering anything in
the chat so that I will be able to
record first and after let you record so
I do a record do you prefer is
initializing I take a type one character
is a little slow I tap enter
and I can stop the record don't record
more than 20 seconds because you will
recall more than that you browser may
hang okay because I will be too much
data for the CPU to process okay so I
let you I give you one minute each five
minute to try to do your own recording
make it simple record on try to make
something complex one one and one
character and one and then you can stop
the profiling
right just just right to do like Joey
one character it will be easier for you
to analyze the profiling
okay so so few people have done it we
can see in the chat right if you cannot
find out forget the Booton is here on
the left record
all right so I will continue okay don't
worry if you do not have time to do the
recording
what's important is here to show what
exactly you can do with this recording
okay
after you can can't try to play with you
on recording if you want so here you see
there's this bottom part which happy
after I finish the recording so it's a
little hard to read because it's a
little stir everything is better stacked
so I'm going here on the right the 3.2
docksiders fullscreen okay now I have
everything I have the same my
console.log now appear as a full screen
so that I can see more information so
what we see here the first bar shaft
here let me remove this you can see when
I'll go along the way it's showing me
the screen how is it going so we can see
clearly that there was nothing at the
beginning right the message is empty
so the message is empty okay along here
something is happening we tape we enter
the character a nothing is happening and
then something again is happening and at
the end we can see that the message has
been don't all in the chat okay how to
read this job so the first information
here you can see is the CPU usage and
the color here this is describing is how
the CP is being used and we can see that
most of the time here the CPUs edge is
on scripting run the ring and penting is
when he tried to change your browser the
HTML in in the browser okay so this is a
two part that will ensure interest to
try to find out what's how to improve
the performance so if you go a little
below so frame here I can see how long
if I select this this part here I can
select now he tell me when that how long
it took to do this action here
interaction you can see that there is
the key character and the key up which
is when I tap when I enter the a
character and we can see in user timing
here this is what is interesting
starting to be interesting we can see
the different react component overlap
that when I enter a he render again he
executes some rendering for each of the
component the chat we can see the
container the chat container and so on
so there's more information below here
okay we are going to analyze that a
little later
another thing interesting here if I go
from here to here I can see a small
difference right here when I entered the
character it's immediately starting to
run down the component when here when I
start to enter the widest i input enter
there was some latency here he didn't
start to render the component so this is
where maybe we can think of something is
happening why is it so slow to start
running a component I just click 'enter
all right so how to try to find
something does another thing here in
domain which is also some even up
happening the start of the event and the
end of the event until the what's
happening and under the seven the child
local if I click on it and I go here too
but Annette I will see different
function that has been called you are
Tooting interesting one is but on that
wall is call three so the call tree show
you when after I click this one the
different event call the child of the
event caller so sometimes is not it's
not easy to read because there's a lot
of stuff is coming from react is coming
from an anonymous caller and one and so
on okay
so you won't always find something but
you still interesting to have a look
first just in case the bottom up we'll
regroup together for the same function
if it had been called many time it will
put together the time that has been
spent on a specific function and here I
can see clearly how we function here
called update mention message the
aggregation of call took 68 millisecond
okay
out of the three 360 millisecond but if
you look in term of aggregation he was
the one taking more the most time
compared to all the other small function
call and here on the right you can see
mutate auto Jess
so this one is possible the chrome can
make the link to new code because on
development mod there was a soft color
what's this color sauce mapping so so
smacking is Bill when you are building
your react code this was mapping allow
the force when you debugging when I
click here he will be able to go to the
code okay so how did I go here just to
come back I click here on the event
press if you cannot click sometime is a
little bug on the chrome do a
right-click you just a PR this and then
you should be able to click it okay
everyone has this so I go back again to
what they I go back here to the bottom
up I can see update munch and each edge
is taking a lot long time when we
aggregate the time span and if I go to
the code itself I can see okay here very
something very easy I've written we are
doing your loop for nothing
okay this is what make or up a little
slow a little slower so now just to show
you that we can improve it
so then I managed to find a specific
piece of code that should not be there
so I'm going to remove it so you can
find it inside the meet at all okay a
one can go to the mutator and the piece
of code is here right we have the line
with eight other GS 9 28 so again see
here imitate other GS
line 15 no maybe are some compilation as
yes okay there was some compilation from
webpack so there is a difference of line
I forgot this one but but that's fine
that's easy to find because anywhere we
have the we have the name of the
function and we did an equal if I or
minify okay so now I'm just going to
comment this code the code is going to
be recompile
okay and I'm going to reinitialize it
just to make sure I start from scratch
log in again and I'm going to do another
recording so here is a still a little
slower because I'm still working okay if
you want to stop rolling you can change
back the sitting here so mg are going to
keep those for changes to compare so
this let's have a comparison here to see
that the time taken is one second and
the time and to remember here we have a
small gap of a few 300 millisecond about
three hundred and second so I record
again
so the provider is initializing okay I
do the same the same action a and though
I stopped the profiling
and know if I come back here the second
part oh I think someone yes someone
joined the chat to let me redo it again
okay so just for the sake of the
exercise just hold a little on your chat
so I do it again I enter a and I stop
the profiling now we can see the second
part here once I enter the key there's
no more this latency okay if I click on
the on the event key press we can see
that the update mention massage is no
longer the aggregated time that takes
the most time during the initialization
okay so this one it was very easy to
find because I voluntarily put inside
the function so but don't forget that if
you have a lot of callback function and
on me cause it won't be that easy to
find but you still have first a first
indication that can be useful to try to
find something happening maybe if you
have a service file or this kind of
stuff you will find out something is
happening in your service file okay so
the next tool I want to show you before
going to the next tool let's try to
analyze a little more okay because I'm
still short link and you can see when I
enter a character it's still very slow
right maybe that's something we can do
about this so let's go to the part where
and saw the character you watch this
part here now if you if you look at
again at this part here we can see this
from graph when you see this kind of
stuff behind the front graph is that
maybe something wrong is happening
because you don't want to have a flam
graph that has a lot of bit a lot of
spike like this if you look at it we can
see clearly what is happening in the in
the react when I tap on top here and
again the chat here is the over
different style deep component being
rerender he can render the chat
container and inside the check container
we can see all these chat bubble already
stopped over here you see all of them
are being Rhonda which means there's
something wrong in our logic is every
time I type
he is rendering this horse tough here
but we don't need to under it right
because I'm just
I put here so this is a waste of time
and other tools that will help you to
find this easily if you go now to the
react so this is the next slide if you
go to react the react tool you have this
highlight update
so before I activate it I know I will
remove the short link because I don't
need it anymore okay
so I activate here the highlight okay
let me put this back on the bottom of my
application and what's the difference
now is every time I type he had liked me
the change of your component okay to
change what is halide mean it means he
has been he has been launching a
rendering of the component the color
that you see here blue green sometimes
it will become yellow or red
it's how often this component is being
is being written down so if you see
something that is red maybe is no more
if you are doing like scrolling or this
kind of stuff maybe you wonder why why
is it or run during so many time okay so
maybe something is happening and here we
can see clearly every time I tap
he's running your whole application so
did something all you can try to do
about it but to do something about it we
need to understand exactly how the react
is working okay so if I just go back to
this to this shaft here in fact when you
see here when I click this before a tree
or whenever I was clicking outside we
can remember most of the time during
this react component rerun bearing we
can see that most of the time is spent
on on JavaScript on scripting not on not
on changing the browser UI the HTML and
the interface the CSS because the part
that is the rendering and painting
almost nothing okay so what what is
taking that much time who know what is
taking that much time
no okay so in react I don't know if you
already heard about this their each
component of react is building a virtual
Dom okay meaning that each component
before going the Dome of the browser
will keep a virtual Dom his own abstract
Dom okay
and every time we run though he will
build he will he will execute the code
to run down the Dom okay the rundown of
the Dom is on a component if I go to
chat is that when I do this Rhonda this
is what will be changed as a react
element that will be the abstract
representing the astrodome franzese's I
stop John what is going to do is going
to compare with the real DOM and he's
going to replace it if the real dome is
different okay but what takes time here
so what we see the scripting here is not
the fact that I'm doing a culture is
okay that I'm doing a dispatch that I'm
doing a some mutation what text time is
the is the building of this virtual Dom
so this is what we want to our God
because here we can see we are building
hundreds of chat beber
each of this is a component and we are
rebuilding it 100 time and we can see
the accumulation make the rendering much
more slow the major rending of the whole
hub slower before we get this character
being displayed okay so this is what we
try to do so how does it do that so in
fact there's another tools that that
react provide for each component we have
a function called should of the short
component update so short component
update is part of the lifecycle of a
component okay so each component before
rendering will execute some lifecycle
lifecycle function one of them is true
component update one of them is
component deed model component update
this kind of stuff okay but the one we
interesting is this one because you can
see in this so in this tree each node is
a react component okay so let's say for
those World War or Nazi one is our chat
then over Nazi tree
maybe is a chat container and the notice
is c c6 c7 or c8 is will be all our chat
bubble okay so one is red it means that
he has been changing the Dom in the HTML
when
is green it means he didn't change the
Dom in the HTML okay but to do this
decision of changing the Dom or not in
the HTML you will execute two
functionality one is a short component
update by default it always returning
true so for all the component will
always say yes I want you to update it
when something change in the in the tree
of the of the of the component and then
the second function that is really cute
is what we just say he's going to build
a virtual Dom and then we make a
comparison is the virtual Dom different
or not okay so if you look at this tree
what happened in our chat app is see one
when I check when I enter something the
state is changing and the view dispatch
dispatch the stock change the change of
state and it will it will be connected
to our chat apps component that will
start the rendering so he will say true
component update is true by default and
here then he will compile the visceral
Dom it has change or not if there's a
change yes he will change it for each of
the strategy we will do the same the
chat container will compare it and the
shift component by default is true and
the virtual Dom cooperation will say all
co2 side are some difference because the
input is different so he will render it
no in fact he will not render it because
sorry I'm on the chat container so he
will say all the message is the same so
I don't need to render it but he still
executed the virtual Dom equivalent okay
and after that and for each of them
he will also execute the scenes a short
component of date has been no no he will
execute also for each of the bubble here
what we want to do is to avoid this
rendering so we want to to play with the
shoot component update to come from this
node c3 to do not see to for the part of
the check container okay so how to do
that
if you go back to the code so here you
have your chat right which is below in
your root Chad Chad ogea this chat
reminder is the whole chat here right
the schema that John showed you at the
beginning it was the whole component
inside the chat you can see I have a
chat container okay
this cat chat container is here if I
open the index file I can see my
component here okay and to be able to to
create this functional component update
you have to make a class component as a
class okay so here is already the case
and I put here I put your here the
function you can just uncomment it so
what happened as I told you this
function exists but by default is doing
that is always returning true so he
every time you want to run doubt we just
say yes you try to render it so what we
want to do now is to stop to render in
case the chat list didn't change how do
we do that this function take as the
first parameter the next prop okay if
you are working in the state it will
also take as a second character a second
parameter the next date okay in our case
we don't care about the state we're
working obviously props okay and what I
do is I look if my current props the the
chat props which is the over list of
message is different from the next one
if it's different from the next one then
it means yes I need to render it but if
is not different then no I don't want to
render it okay so let's see this in
action no my chat up should have been
rebuilt okay I will connect again
I open again the inspector okay let me
put it back at the bottom so I highlight
again the updates and no I click you can
see here this is not it surely is not
wander anymore if I do know the the
profiling so I put it back I do the same
configuration oops sorry
with the throttling 4x I do another
recording okay so just to be in the same
situation is empty I do a recording and
tell one character are you enter no in
fact I don't care about you interest me
I do another recording because what we
won't know we what we optimize it was
the fact that I when I input a character
all the Bible should not be updating so
let's do it again
I enter the character multiple time okay
so I have my profiling wait
okay let me do again because people are
answering the chat once again okay just
don't enter the chat for one second so I
do
ay-ay-ay and let's see this in full
screen now you can see here there's a
big difference right if I look at this
part here before it was taking a few
hundred oh it is BA yeah I know it's
very small because there's no much no no
you see so you can see before it was
taking like one second
no it's take only fifties even a second
and we can see also if i zoom again a
little more the blue graph is much more
nicer no more all this chat bubble
rendering he just executed the tree when
he arrived to the container
he doesn't render the dish at container
okay he just runs out the message input
at the end which is where we entered the
a okay
so this is possible because we are
comparing here the chats which means we
are what we do here is a UK food is a
shallow comparison it means we are not
comparing the content of the chat we are
comparing the reference of the chat okay
which is where imitability is very
important because if you chat the
content didn't change you want to send
back the same the same object to same
reference but if you chat change you
want to send a new reference so that's
why you make it immutable so that is a
new object that is created with a new
list because we are not going to compare
the list we are just going to compare
the reference is that clear okay
so I repeat immutability means every
time you you change something in the
object you are not modifying the object
itself you are creating a new object and
changings copy everything in the new
object and checking something inside
this new object which means you will
have two different reference and this is
what is being compared here the
reference not the content which is very
important to understand why is it
working okay because if you have to
compare everything inside it will be
much more complex and also it will take
much more time so maybe we are going to
lose time instead of gaining time okay
that's it this is something very common
right but it will be a little little
annoying if I have a mini props and I
have to compare all them all of them one
by one so what
reiax has done he has provides you
another component called pure component
ok so this poor component you can import
it directly from the reactor so instead
of doing extending a component I will
extend the pure component okay so I'm
going to go a little faster because we
have only 20 min left and add other
thing I would like to show you ok so if
I replace it up to component now I don't
need anymore this should update
component because he will do exactly the
same thing he will take all the props of
the of the chat and he will compare it
to see if there's a change if there's no
chance he will return force it has one
change he will return true so if I do
that I expect the same thing happening
now in my apps sorry
so let me remove the throttling because
I don't need to record anymore we just
show the change in the highlight so does
it work I know it's not working why can
someone try to I give you I give you one
minute because it's interesting exercise
to do can you try to find out what the
pro component does that work as expected
because we expect the component to do
the same comparison a shallow
compression on each props but in this
case even though I'm sending the same
data the same I'm doing the same action
he still rendering the Babur
it means it return true if one of the
one of the props is different otherwise
he return false and he disguises
returning true but it should not be
returning to it should be right on in
false because my my Bubber here is not
changing okay so why if nobody has has
fine it I will show you why it's because
if you look at the chat here when I pass
my chat container I'm passing two props
I passing a chat this is the one we were
comparing manually and we are passing a
container ref which is another props and
the way we pass the container ref is you
see here is a function and this function
every time the chat is rerun during he
will create a new reference of the
function every time there will be a new
installation of a function object that's
why even though we are doing poke
opponent he is comparing both of them
and the container ref will always be a
new reference to a new function so to
avoid that what you need to do is to
have a constant so either it is not a
function is just a constant like
constant value you can create a cons
here so that so that it will always send
back send back the same variable okay so
that the reference will never change
every time you render again this
component it is a function what you can
do is you create it here in a ref as
part of your component you apply the
same code so chat container pops red
container here
oops is the attribute and don't forget
in a react when you want to do this use
this inside the function inside the
function inside the component you need
to bind it okay so I will have to bind
this is part of a reactor if you want to
learn more about this you can look at
the you can check on the real
documentation why you need to bind okay
there's another library that make and I
can help you to bind automatically but I
didn't install it so for just for this
exercise I will just directly bind say I
want to bind this the current is of this
of this component to the disk of this
function so that is this will be the
same okay by doing that now I can tell
him every time you run down when you
watch you pass in the props I don't want
you to instantiate a new function I
won't use to use to use the same
function so now let's try to have a look
at the chat oops
Alex for I highlight the updates and we
can see it's working right so be careful
about this this is one one trick that
can can happen often you think you are
using a pro component and is doing the
correct comparison but if you are not a
single constant or you are not passing
the same reference it will change it
again
so again imitability is a very important
concept for this to walk as a pure
component okay but then what is true
also and don't don't forget that emit a
shallow comparison is only on the
reference so if you are not doing
immutability correctly it will not do
the comparison correctly and you can
have some unexpected behavior okay
the next thing I want to show you is
another library called recompose because
here what we did to do this a short
component update we had to make a
component as a class ok because for
those who knows or for those who doesn't
know react has many way of creating this
component class one ways to create a
class the other way is to create a knob
component as a function when you create
a class we are we are sometime we had to
come construct all we had many lines of
code which could be creating more works
so some people doesn't like to do that
especially if you do a present rational
component there's no need to have
complex class so what what there's a
library called recompose it's already
installed if you didn't pay me install
is already in the package or JSON if you
go to mention so mention is an example
of here of component that is used a
function there's no class here but since
there's no class I cannot add this
should component update
so this recompose allow me to is a
different type of higher-order component
okay is another principle in redux in
JavaScript you have the principle of
high order function so you do the same
with hydro component is the taking
something each parameter and will return
you a component okay
so here I can do import out before I do
that just to show you we can see here
that every time I type here you see this
path here if you look at dimension every
time I type we can see a square on
motion image is being rerun the right
well the same we don't want to render it
we're under it because there is no point
to changing the mention when I'm typing
so I will use a pure off from recompose
slash pure and only thing one thing I
need to do is just pure I am capsulate I
encapsulate the component so that you so
that is sent back a new component that
will execute also a short component
update like pure component and now if I
login okay
I need to highlight your date so I can
see mansion is not being run there
anymore
okay so they are this recompose for
people who is interested there are many
other higher-order component like a
shrewd update while oh you are so to
personalize you should component update
and order high order component that you
can have a look okay the next library
the next things to know is about redux
right we use radix no application in
fact if you use radix you don't need to
do this through component update or
disappear component because radix is
doing it for you
we're inside the inside this function
when you do the connect for radix when
you're connecting your component to your
store there is a multiple parameter map
state two probes map this part to pro
smells props and the last one is option
and by default the option has a pure
attribute that will be true and that
will do this comparison he will when you
finish to map the state to prop he will
compare the previous props to your new
props and he will do the same he will he
will he will return true component
update to true or false depending if
there's a change in the props so quickly
here in the check container I can show
you you can see here this this object is
not linked to the store does is just
exporting it so I'm going to link it
grisco just here there's a file index
reduce your taste a I'm just going to do
some copy past okay so I'm taking this
code I change from the export so what I
did here is I connected my chap to the
store and I say every time the state
what I do is I send to chat the chat
props from the state so every time the
chat will change he will this component
will be R under every time the chat list
which change this component will be
runned off okay and here since we are
using imitability when I do state
block get in the chat list will not
change because the action that we are
doing in when inputting your character
will not change with no change your chat
list so he will do a comparison and the
same he will he will see that the chat
reference didn't change and he will not
update the component
okay so quickly it was last time okay I
still have 15 minute so I can see here
let's remove pure component to make sure
you are really not applying any short
component should component buy it by
default no is a true because I didn't I
commented this function and I'm not
doing a pure component anymore okay so
no okay just reload everything to make
sure just to show you that we are really
having the latest code so every time I
type oh I like two digits the same no
this chat container that I connected to
the stock he's comparing when I
connected the story is comparing the
reference you see that the reference
doesn't change so he's not rendering it
again okay so this is why some people
say you need to split you you need to
split your application when using Redux
this is where splitting your application
into multiple linking the correct
component to the correct state will also
do optimization behind okay but behind
is still shallow comparison so you have
to understand that this will work the
same as the pure component that should
component update that we created
manually only comparing reference okay
and this is why I saw this one this part
here doing export default connect and
send say I want to link my my apps to
the whole global state means you are not
optimizing anymore because every time
there will be a change on the state even
it is not linked to your component he
will render this component again okay so
this should be avoided or
if you do it is really one component
I'll really need to have everything in
the state which may be the case for
small small application which you have
if you have a big state with a lot of
information inside inside your store
then normally you should link the
correct component to the current correct
part of the state
okay so comparison is still shallow okay
but there's the last tool that I will
present you for is sense for this
workshop is the reselect okay so if you
look at why why does it matter that is
that is doing a shallow comparison is
that here when you do much state two
props sometimes the probes that you want
to return maybe is not exactly the state
inside it you want to do some
some recomputation calculation fiiiing
reduce or whatever and since you are
doing maybe a new array
he will always send you back a new
reference of this sorry so it means it
doesn't matter that he compared the two
deuce even even in the state to do and
the state visible filter doesn't change
because of this function you are going
to return the new reference so the
previous to do reference and the new
reference calculated by this function
will be different so even though the
content can be the same because we
didn't change it to do or the visible
filter it will recalc it will or maybe
we change it but the calculation
returned the same content it will still
rear under everything
so there's another tool called reselect
let allow you to improve this editor so
what does wrestle I do the difference
you can see here now my get visible to
do instead of simply sending back a new
reference we are going to use a create
select off from reselect okay so this
great selector what is going to do is
going to to take in parameter some
selectors which are these two function
and if the selectors see that the state
inside that we are using didn't change
he will return the previous result so
kind of the create select all cache the
previous props the reference to the
preview props and we write on it if you
see that what you are trying to to use
as you fold your calculation here didn't
change so the same is a shallow
comparison but at another level okay if
a behind below you change it
what is comparing is used the visible
filter okay the the reference but this
allow you to improve also this this off
the first program that now you know
every time is going to return the
different reference now in case the
content of the state didn't change he's
going to send it is not going to do this
calculation he's going to send you back
the previous reference okay so if you if
you really need to optimize you up then
you can think about this one as a part
of your radix way of building the
application let's say you don't need to
think it from the start because maybe
there's no optimization to do and this
could be heavy to implement so but once
you have some assured and you can start
to think about if this can help you
instead of having to do a some manual
trick to make sure we return the same
reference this could be useful
okay so in summary for decision what I
show you is the prediction bill don't
forget that there's two built-in react
second thing which shows we look at some
tools using Chrome and the react
developer extension in chrome okay to
show this Flamm graph and to also have
this highlight of your component life
then we speak about how that's true
component update with the virtual Dom
recalculation and comparison the pure
component that is doing a kind of easy
way for you to compare the props and the
Redax that is doing it for you if you
already that you don't need to care
about tor component and should component
update if you are linking the correct
state we took with your component the
correct slice of the state we show
component don't forget that is shallow
compression so immutability is very
important for this to work okay and I
present it some library like recompose
we select you have other library that
could help you from optimization I
didn't speak about this one why should
you update forever is also linked to
reduce and we'll console.log a lot of
thing to suggest you you are rerun the
ring something but the property don't
change okay so you can play with this
tool also if you want by yourself okay
so I think that's all for this session I
hope it was interesting so I think your
team all the team thank you for for
coming here before you leave we have
some tea shop okay but maybe we can take
some questions I think we have some time
right yeah so we still have 10 minutes
anyone has any question about the one of
the three workshop about the
one question
yes yeah using Redux so far so far you
know on the project we are using your
lot with ducks okay me because it follow
us to do all this optimization and we
are it's quite macho I didn't know we
didn't play with Mobe X or the state
management so I will not say which one
is the best but the red X is quite it's
quite famous and also is using the
concept conflicts so that's why this is
why it become a very streamlined and
it's really dude it's really doing the
job that we need but I cannot tell you
about the other or the framework because
we don't play it to tell you if it's
what are the pros and cons I was very
interesting how you
you know I was I was thinking we would
have to keep this onion in Redux with
that seems messenger in the Redux store
but that seems wrong so I like your way
problem we have is our login doesn't
create we don't have the socket when we
set up the store so in that case I was
thinking I could just past an empty
object to the same reason can you repeat
the part when you say that when Redux
have no strong something in it yet so we
we don't have the sockets when we first
set up the store okay we haven't created
it it's only when they hit the login
button that we create a socket no
actually when we apply the middleware so
so when the when the application load
the JavaScript actually ran the part
where we initialize the cockatrice
object oh okay okay later but can I just
can I just pass an empty object to the
middleware and then the socket into the
object later I think it depends on how
we how do you want to do it because the
thing on the socket is that you want to
listen to the events right so if you're
passing like an empty object when the
application load the socket is not
initialized here at all so if any event
is coming in your you can you can you
can't execute anything because the
socket then and the object that you're
passing in so the way to do it is to
find somewhere when your application
loads or before prior to when you need
your socket connection you have to
initialize the socket object and of
course listen to the wavers event that
you are listening to yeah
thank you yep that's one questions is
still say if there's a state that'll
trigger of multiple actions how would
you like trivia tea actions is I tried
and my googling tells me how to use a
batch action measure like and why can't
we use in the loop okay so when you want
to dispatch multiple actions so that's
in Vedas AK right the one that we use he
actually happy if you look at the
documentation there's actually one
function that allows you to dispatch
we should mention that's right to
dispatch multiple actions we are not
doing that but what we are doing is
instead of dispatching multi-position
because normally when dispatch multiple
actions it could be you want to clear
this you want to stop this loader you
want to do that thing so what we are
doing if you look at our reducer which
we have right we have a pipe function
right so we are actually piping to a
different set of mutaters so we are
actually only using one action that is
like doing a series of things in there
so the good thing is that if you
dispatch like multiple actions you all
read your application might render a few
times right so that might be some create
office performance so what we are doing
is one action is dispatch where every
mutaters change the state but the state
that we are changing we are not
returning it to the video so yes so it
doesn t vendors app so the the state
from one mutator to the neck right for
example here you can see we add a new
message
it changes the state the current state
pass to the next state convention it
does something to it and pass through
the one and do it and so now we have a
new state has been modified by audit
mutaters and i will return it to the
video sir and so there's a few changes
there but
we went at one time yeah okay
any more questions okay thank you very
much for coming hope you enjoyed we have
t-shirts I think we have any t-shirts
but I don't know what sizes so please
come over and collect your t-shirts now
or you can yeah we'll distribute it you
guys
[Music]